the taliban shocked the world when it
took control of afghanistan but what may
surprise you is how they funded their
campaign
afghanistan is one of the poorest
countries in the world in march 2021
world bank described its economy as
shaped by fragility and aid dependence
but there is one surefire way to make
money in afghanistan the drug trade
afghanistan produces between 80 and 90
of the global supply of illegal opium a
key ingredient in heroin
opium production is an easy access it
feeds families it feeds
poor people it's a big business with
huge swathes of land dedicated to poppy
fields
it is estimated that one-fifth of
afghanistan's gdp comes from the opium
trade and the taliban play a part in
every aspect of it
they're involved in the growing
cultivating and trafficking of the drug
as well as taxing cultivators and drug
labs
and charging smugglers fees for
shipments not only do the farmers
conservative but some of their children
their family members then become heroin
addicts they will start using it and the
opium that comes and is sent over to
across europe also comes into different
communities in coral backgrounds in
britain for example my own entire
hamlets so it's a vicious circle
although it has been out of power since
2001
the taliban has always controlled
pockets of the country and in those
areas they introduced taxation policies
as well as taxes for travelling through
them
the taliban are also involved in the
illegal mining trade afghanistan is full
of extremely valuable minerals like
copper cobalt oil and gas
the taliban controls small extraction
sites as well as extorting money out of
other more legitimate ones
they also raise money through suspected
foreign investments from sympathetic
countries as well as looting areas they
take control of and keeping the spoils
of war
the taliban's takeover has sparked a
humanitarian crisis but also a
potentially huge economic one
afghanistan's economy is reliant on
foreign aid and grants and much of that
is up in the air
most countries around the world have
refused to recognize their government so
far
meaning receiving the same level of aid
or financial help is unlikely
the taliban have also promised to ditch
the opium trade
in an attempt to appear like a
legitimate government
but this leaves them with limited ways
of making money
there have been talks of foreign
investment in the country with china
reportedly keen to get involved in that
lucrative mineral business but this is
yet to actually lead to anything
concrete
another big problem is since the taliban
were removed from power in 2001
female employment has risen from zero
percent to 22 percent
the taliban leadership say they will let
women continue to work
but some have questioned whether this
will actually happen if women's right to
work is revoked then that takes a huge
portion of the tax-paying population
out of the workforce creating yet
another economic headache for
afghanistan's new leaders